[Music]
what's interesting is that hope in
particular seems to have a kind of
really low barrier for cognitive
consistency so as long as I don't
believe something to be impossible it
seems to be an object that's at least
possible for me to hope for so I don't
think it's impossible and I don't think
it's certain it seems to be a candidate
for hope and insofar as then my desire
for it kicks in and it engages my agency
in the right sorts of ways it seems like
I can't actually hope for it so in the
religious tradition there's a lot of
work that's been done on of course hope
and particularly the relation between
hope and other of the so called
theological virtues faith and love and
one of things we were interested in and
has to do with the connection between
state and hope so a lot of people think
of faith as having a kind of belief
commitment that something is going to be
certain or that something is going to be
probable that maybe outstrips the
evidence and the interesting thing about
Hope is that it seems to kind of float
free from judgments about the evidence
so you can hope for something even
though you really don't believe it's
likely to come about and so one of the
things we were interested in with this
project is when it comes to the
religious context what sorts of
religious practices does mirror hoping
cultivate so for instance suppose you
were someone who had religious beliefs
but for various reasons have come to
believe other things maybe become
agnostic about the existence of God say
but nevertheless do you still hope that
God exists and if you do hope that God
exists what sorts of practices does that
kind of hoping sort of inspire is it
possible to hopefully pray even though
you don't actually believe that God
exists can you still pray and hope can
you participate in religious practices
and communities even though you don't
actually endorse the beliefs necessarily
anymore but nonetheless you're still
hope for an afterlife where you hope for
the unity of virtue and happiness in the
end so what sorts of distinctive beliefs
and practices can we get if we have hope
with
out say with respect to the religious
situation as long as I don't believe
that the existence of God say is
logically impossible and few even sort
of adamant atheists would say it's
logically impossible that God exists or
that they're absolutely certain that God
doesn't exist just like most theists
would not say they're absolutely certain
that God exists so here we are we're
between absolute impossibility and
certainty well that's the perfect space
for hope to operate in and so in a way
hope and in the religious context
doesn't necessarily involve assessment
of the odds or the probability in the
way that maybe faith would and so as
long as you can think yeah there's a
consistent narrative in some particular
religious tradition even if I'm not sure
that it's true or even I don't even
think it's likely that's true
nonetheless you might engage in the kind
of hope that say the Christian God
exists and in doing so that might
actually motivate certain kinds of
religious practices so I think it's
definitely the case that we can do
certain things that put us in a position
to have robust deep abiding hopes and so
in that sense I do think hope can be
under the volitional control of an agent
it might not be the sort of thing that I
can just bootstrap my way into on a dime
and so if on a snap or something like
that
I just magically start hoping but can I
do things that I know if I'm in the
right community context I'm in the right
sort of situation it will in fact
instill in me desires it will in fact
instill in me a sense of agency and
urgency over the object of my desires
and will help me see the possibility
space for those desires being realized
that's exactly the kind of situation I
actually do have control over putting
myself in and insofar as I do that it
does seem like I can sort of indirectly
put myself in a position to inculcate
deep rich sustaining hopes
[Music]